[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne
gellineck guten Abend die Frau des
ukrainischen präsidenttin Olena selenska
richtete an diesem Wochenende in der BBC
einen leidenschaftlichen ell an die Welt
und die een Leute wir dürfen nicht müde
werden in dieser Situation denn wenn wir
das tun sterben wir und wenn die Welt
müde wird werden Sie uns einfach sterben
len sagte selenska sie hat Grund zur
Sorge denn Milliarden Euro Militärhilfen
stecken sowohl im amerikanischen
Kongress als auch in Europa Fest der
zweite Kriegswinter hat begonnen und
militärische Erfolge bleiben aus wie
soll man da nicht müde werden Tim Kröger
berichtet aus einer erschöpften
Ukraine sie trotzen Schnee und Kälte um
für ihre Männer zu demonstrieren die als
Soldaten oftmals seit Beginn des Krieges
an der Front kämpfen die meisten der
Männer seinen völlig erschöpft und
müssten endlich ausgetauscht also
demobilisiert werden fordern die
Frauen ich sehe es so mein Mann hat die
Kinder von anderen beschützt jetzt ist
es an der Zeit dass andere Eltern die
Kinder beschützen es ist Zeit für einen
Austausch den Frauen schlägt auch
Ablehnung entgegen dennoch die Moral der
Soldaten leide sagen viele hier und
fordern eine begrenzte Einsatzzeit dafür
müssten tausende neue Soldaten
rekrutiert werden aber die Mobilisierung
laufe nicht gut sagen die
Frauen unsere Männer die am 24 februar
in den Krieg zogen haben nicht nur den
Feind abgewährt sondern unserer
Staatsführung auch etwas Zeit gegeben
sich vorzubereiten Schulungen zu
organisieren eine angemessene
Mobilisierung zu
und zwar nicht im
Notfallmodus nach der erfolglosen
Großoffensive im Sommer herrscht längst
ein zermirbungskrieg und je länger er
dauere desto mehr nehme die Diskussion
zu sagt der ukrainische Journalist
Dennis trubzg ich glaube die der
Zeitpunkt jetzt der hält wirklich so ein
bisschen damit zusammen dass die
Hoffnung die ukrainische Gesellschaft
auf dieses Jahr hat militärisch gesehen
dass sie sich nicht erfüllt haben die
Regierung will nun durch Reformen
Korruption und verkrustete Strukturen in
den rekrutierungsämtern beseitigen das
einberufungsalter soll wahrscheinlich
gesenkt und neue Gesetze erarbeitet
werden es geht nicht nur um die Anzahl
derjenigen die eingezogen werden können
es geht auch um die Bedingung für eine
Demobilisierung für jene die gerade in
der Armee
dienen Einheiten wie die dritte Brigade
werben schon jetzt direkt um neue
Soldaten private rekrutierungsagenturen
mobilis online gezielter neue
Kämpfer wir geben den Anwärtern die
Möglichkeit die konkrete Einheit und
Funktion zu wählen und berücksichtigen
Stärken und Schwächen sowie die
Bereitschaft mehr oder weniger Risiko
einzugehen die Frauen sind schon viermal
auf die Straße gegangen auch weil die
Ukraine mit erschöpften Soldaten an der
Front nicht gewinnen
könne der russische Präsident Putin
lobte heute bei einem Empfang mel die
eigene Rüstungsindustrie sie produziere
ein Vielfaches mehr als die Ukraine
Putin verfolgt natürlich dass Europa der
Ukraine gerade mal knapp ein Drittel der
zugesagten Artilleriegeschosse geliefert
hat sein Interesse ist es den Krieg in
die Länge zu ziehen womöglich bis ein
neuer amerikanischer Präsident namens
Donald Trump ins Weiße Haus einziehen
und die
usmitärhilfen für die Ukraine ganz
einstellen könnte die Europäer haben die
Möglichkeit von Trump 2 lange ignoriert
vielleicht zu lange wie unser
natokorrespondent Florian Neuhann
berichtet ein Gespenst geht um in Europa
was wenn dieser Mann in einem Jahr in
den USA wieder ans Ruder kommt wenn sich
Europa dann wohl nicht mehr auf den
Schutzschirm der NATO verlassen
könnte als Donal Trump kam wurde Europa
kalt erwischt schon damals hielt Trump
die NATO für überflüssig doch gerade so
konnte der Rest ihn überzeugen drin zu
bleiben Trump 2.0 wäre wohl um einiges
gefährlicher in der ersten Amtszeit
haben wir gesehen dass ein Trump von den
Institutionen in Schach gehalten wurde
vom Kongress von den Gerichten und von
seinen eigenen Mitarbeitern die häufig
sehr viel konventionell Reflexe hatten
und das Schlimmste zu verhindern
versucht
es ist inzwischen sehr klar dass eine
zweite Amtszeit das alles nicht mehr
vorsehen würde Trump zum zweiten das
wäre Trump pur Europa müsste sich selbst
schützen schon Geistern radikale Ideen
durch die Landschaft Ex Außenminister
Joschka Fischer fordert die EU braucht
eine eigene atomare Abschreckung die EU
Atomwaffe unrealistisch sagen NATO
Insider es gibt zwei nukleare
Großbritannien und Frankreich beide
werden ihr Potenzial nicht europäisieren
lassen also andere mitreden lassen die
Vorstellung über
Massenvernichtungswaffen gemeinsame
Entscheidungen treffen zu können gehört
aus meiner Sicht ins Reich der Fantasie
was also dann Interview mit einer der
wichtigsten mnerinnen Europas der
estnischen Premierministerin Kaja KAS
die nicht auf neue Waffen schaut sondern
aufs
Geld unabhängig davon wer der nächste
US-Präsident wird wir müsen definitiv
mehr in unsere eigene Verteidigung
investieren wenn wir diese Entscheidung
jetzt nicht treffen in D Jahren könnte
es zu spät
sein einerseits haben die EU-Staaten
seit 2014 ihre Ausgaben für Verteidigung
deutlich gesteigert andererseits kommen
sie auch zusammen nur auf ein Drittel
dessen was die USA ausgeben und so
schlägt KAS vor zu wiederholen was man
schon einmal
tat schauen Sie wie wir auf die
covid-krise reagiert haben da waren wir
schnell weil es ein gemeinsames Problem
war und wir haben gemeinsam Schulden
aufgenommen und jetzt haben wir eine
neue ähnliche
Krise neue Schulden aufnehmen da winken
viele ab Deutschland erst recht und so
starren sie auch auf den Fluren der NATO
weiter gebannt auf dieses Gespenst noch
hat Europa ein Jahr Zeit sich
vorzubereiten darüber wollen wir reden
mit Nico lange Militärexperte der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz davor
führte er den leitungsstab des
Bundesverteidigungsministeriums guten
Abend Herr Lange Abend fr gellineck
bleiben wir mal bei der möglichen
Wiederwahl von Donald Trump was würde
Trump 2 für die NATO und die europäische
Sicherheit konkret bedeuten es bedeutet
Unsicherheit
Unberechenbarkeit und es bedeutet auch
dass man sich nicht darauf verlassen
kann dass die Vereinigten Staaten für
immer für unsere Sicherheit sorgen
werden und wir müssen als Europäer in
der Lage sein mehr selbst zu tun das
betrifft militärische Fähigkeiten auch
industrielle Fähigkeiten das kann man
aber nicht über Nacht machen da muss man
jetzt und es ist schon ganz schön spät
aber jetzt damit beginnen diese
Fähigkeiten aufzubauen das hören wir
jetzt ja schon eigentlich seit Trump 1
dass die Europäer mehr tun müssen
angenommen ein Präsident Trump zöge die
US Atomwaffen aus Europa ab wäre die EU
in der Lage zu einer eigenen atomaren
Abschreckung überhaupt ich glaube wir
müssen zunächst mal über die die Frage
der konventionellen Abschreckung
nachdenken damit wir nicht gezwungen
sind auf atomare Dinge zurückzugreifen
und da geht es um Truppenstationierung
an der Ostflanke der NATO da geht es um
Fähigkeiten zu Land zu Luft im Wasser
und im
ziberbereich und diese Dinge müssen eben
so aufgebaut sein dass sie glaubwürdig
sind dass Putin weiß wenn er die
Europäer angreift dann wird er eine
Niederlage erleiden diese
abschreckungsfähigkeit müssen wir
aufbauen und dafür sind wir spät dran
und mit guten Worten allein wird man
Putin nicht beeindrucken können wir
haben es gerade gehört im Beitrag die
estnische Ministerpräsidentin schlägt
eine Art europäischen coronafond für
Rüstung vor wie realistisch ist
das die Frage ist ja wann setzen sich
die Europäer zusammen und diskutieren
diese Fragen um sich selbst für ihre
eigene Sicherheit besser aufzustellen
nur Sorgen machen allein reicht nicht
aus und ich glaube Frau kajas hat da
einen Vorschlag gemacht der sich lohnt
zu diskutieren die Frage der Finanzen
ist ja eine Frage die dann auch
Sicherheit gibt für Industrie und für
Technologieentwicklung und es kann ja
nicht sein dass bestimmte Technologien
für die Sicherheit künftig nur noch in
den USA oder in China verfügbar sind
also sie hat eine wichtige Diskussion
angestoßen und ich hoffe jetzt kommen
bald alle in Europa an einen Tisch aber
das ist natürlich eine sehr langfristige
Perspektive gucken wir mal auf das was
gerade in der Ukraine passiert da sehen
wir jetzt schon einen abnutzungskrieg
Russland rennt mit Mensch und Material
gegen die Ukraine an und keine Seite
kommt so richtig voran gleichzeitig
schwindet ja bereits jetzt schon die
militärische Unterstützung sowohl in den
USA als auch in Europa hat die Ukraine
den Krieg nicht eigentlich schon
verloren die Ukraine kann diesen Krieg
gewinnen Russland ist schlagbar das
wissen wir aus den letzten 21 Monaten
des Krieges aber dafür braucht die
Ukraine unsere Unterstützung die Wahl
vor der wir stehen ist ja nicht zu sagen
die Ukraine bekommt weniger
Unterstützung und dann gibt es
Waffenstillstand und Frieden sondern die
Wahl ist nur entweder wir unterstützen
die Ukraine dass sie sich durchsetzen
kann oder Putin greift immer weiter an
nimmt sich immer mehr der Ukraine
vernichtet dort immer mehr Städte und
auch die Lebensgrundlagen dort Putin
lässt keinerlei Zweifel daran was er
will und er will weiter diesen Krieg
führen mhm jetzt haben wir aber auch
gerade gesehen dass in der Ukraine auch
eine gewisse Frustration einsetzt für
wie erstrebenswert halten sie das
Szenario eines sogen
erschöpfungsfriedens also eine zermürbte
Ukraine die am Ende Russland
Verhandlungen
anbietet Russland ist nicht zu
Verhandlung bereit das haben wir durch
Äußerung gerade heute wieder gehört
russland fordert ja offiziell mindestens
mal die Übergabe der Großstädte hererson
und saparigia um überhaupt zu reden
insofern gibt es diese Option gar nicht
das scheint mir etwas eine Illusion in
unserer Debatte zu sein entweder die
Ukraine wird weiter unterstützt oder wir
werden eine ganz langsames Vorrücken der
russischen Kräfte in der Ukraine sehen
was ist dann auch schlecht für unsere
eigene Sicherheit ist ist unser eigenes
Interesse die Ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen und ich hoffe dass die
Entscheidungen in den USA und auch bei
uns dann so getroffen werden dass die
Ukraine im Frühjahr die Chancen hat sich
da weiter durchzusetzen sagt Nico lange
Militärexperte der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz vielen Dank nach
Berlin
gerne das Gespräch haben wir am frühen
Abend aufgezeichnet und gerade eben
kommt die Meldung dass US-Präsident
Biden seinen ukrainischen Amtskollegen
selenski für Dienstag ins Weiße Haus
eingeladen hat Thema des Treffens soll
die Fortsetzung der us-hilfen in dieser
entscheidenden Phase sein und hier
geht's weiter mit Heinz Wolf und den
Nachrichten und dem Haushaltsloch ja im
Bundeskanzleramt ist für heute Abend
eine weitere Runde zur Haushaltskrise
angesetzt mit Finanzminister Lindner
Vizekanzler habbeck und dem Kanzler Olaf
Scholz hatte auf dem SPD Bundesparteitag
erklärt für ihn sei ganz klar es werde
in einer solchen Situation keinen Abbau
des Sozialstaates in Deutschland geben
der FDP
bundestagsfraktionsvorsitzende dürr
sagte in der ZDF-Sendung Berlin direkt
es gehe nicht darum den Sozialstaat
einzureißen es gehe darum zu schauen wie
man mehr Menschen in Arbeit bringe und
da glaube er sei man sich gar nicht so
uneinig in dieser
Koalition zum Abschluss ihres
Bundesparteitags haben die
Sozialdemokraten Vorschläge für ein
besseres Bildungssystem beschlossen
unter anderem mit einem sogenannten
deutschlandpakt Bildung darin fordert
die SPD ein Sondervermögen für die
Bildung und eine engere Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Bund Ländern und Kommunen in
diesem Bereich zur Finanzierung möchten
die Sozialdemokraten hohe Erbschaften
und sehr hohe Einkommen
Heranziehen der israelische
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu hat die
Kämpfer der Terrororganisation Hamas
aufgefordert ihre Waffen niederzulegen
Netanyahu sagte in einer heute Abend
verbreiteten Videobotschaft in den
letzten Tagen hätten sich dutzende
hamasterroristen ergeben der Krieg werde
noch andauern aber das sei der Anfang
vom Ende der Hamas ein hamasprecher
hatte zuvor eine Fortsetzung der Kämpfe
angekündigt in Berlin gab es heute eine
Demonstration die unter dem Motto stand
nie wieder ist jetzt Deutschland steht
auf mit Unterstützung aus Politik und
Kultur demonstrierten nach
Polizeiangaben gut 3000 Menschen gegen
Antisemitismus Hass und Rassismus zur
gleichen Zeit fand einige Kilometer
entfernt eine proalästinensische
Demonstration mit etwa 2500 Teilnehmern
statt in Magdeburg ist heute die neu
erbaute Synagoge offiziell eröffnet
worden 85 Jahre nach der Zerstörung des
Gotteshauses durch die
Nationalsozialisten an der Feierstunde
nahm unter anderen der Präsident des
Zentralrats der Juden in Deutschland
Schuster Teil sachsenanhaltsminister
Präsident haselow sprach von einem Tag
der Zuversicht der Freude und der
Hoffnung bei der Deutschen Bahn gilt
seit heute ein neuer Fahrplan und damit
verbunden sind Änderungen für Fahrgäste
so gibt es neue zusätzliche Verbindungen
und mehr Züge allerdings erhöht die Bahn
auch ihre Preise um durchschnittlich
4,9% ausgenommen sind die bahncart 50
und alle sparpreistickets die Bahn
verwies auf gestiegene energiekost
geplant sind auch Sanierungen des
Schienennetzes je mehr von uns sie
einsperren desto stärker werden wir
immer wieder schafft es die iranische
Frauenrechtlerin nages Mohammadi solche
Botschaften aus dem Gefängnis in tearan
herauszuschmuggeln Verzeihung und sie
hört nicht auf das Muller Regime
anzuklagen sie kritisiert den
Kopftuchzwang für Frauen prangert
systematische sexuelle Gewalt in
iranischen Gefängnissen an und sprcht
spricht über die sogenannte weiße Folter
Isolationshaft bei ständigem Kunstlicht
heute bekam nages Mohammed mahadi in
Oslo den Friedensnobelpreis verliehen in
Abwesenheit Kamran safiarian
berichtet ihr Stuhl bleibt heute in Oslo
symbolisch leer narges Mohammadi ihre
Zwillinge Kiana und Ali die ihre Mutter
seit fast 9 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen
haben empfangen stellvertreten für Sie
den diesjährigen Friedensnobelpreis
mohammadis Botschaft aus dem Gefängnis
ein Frontalangriff auf das
Regime ich bin eine von Millionen
stolzer und widerstandsfähiger
iranischer Frauen die sich gegen
Ungerechtigkeit Unterdrückung
Diskriminierung und Tyrannei erhoben
haben der Norden teerans hier sitzt NES
Mohammadi im berüchtigten Erwin
Gefängnis ihre Strafe mehr als 30 Jahre
Haft und 154
derzeit ist die 51jährige im
Hungerstreik wegen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen auch gegen
religiöse Minderheiten sie muss dringend
ins Krankenhaus sie hat Lungenprobleme
sie hat Herzprobleme sie ist eigentlich
gar nicht mehr haftfähig aber das Regime
hat gesagt sie kann nur ins Krankenhaus
wenn sie ein Kopftuch trägt und nages
hat sich geweigert das Kopftuch zu
tragen so kämpft nares Mohammadi seit
Jahren für Frauenrechte und gegen die
Todesstrafe sie deckt auf dass Frauen
Männer und Minderjährige im Zuge der
teste 2022 systematisch vergewaltigt und
gequält wurden amnesty International hat
das jetzt bestätigt wer erreichen die
Menschenrechtsanwältin und sacharof
Preisträgerin nasin sotude in te sie
vertritt viele der Opfer kenn NES
Mohammadi und war mit ihr im
Gefängnis diese Hinrichtungen und die
Qualen die Frauen aufgrund ihres
fruseins in den Gefängnissen und
anderswo ertragen mussten aber auch die
Männer vergewaltigt
wurden das alles wird die Bewegung in
Iran nicht
stoppen die Proteste sind vorerst blutig
niedergeschlagen das Regime hat seit dem
Gazakrieg über 100 Menschen hingerichtet
darunter auch Minderjährige fast 700
Hinrichtungen im Jahr
2023 in einem Brief aus dem Gefängnis
prangert Mohammadi die Hinrichtungen
an diese Hinrichtungen sind eine Schande
ist der Wille der internationalen
Gemeinschaft erlarmt diese willkürlichen
und weit verbreiteten Hinrichtungen zu
stoppen bereits 2022 hat Mohammadi ihre
Vision für Iran
formuliert die Menschen in Iran wollen
eine Demokratie und die Achtung der
Menschenrechte wir werden nicht aufgeben
bis wir dieses Ziel erreicht haben eines
Tages werden wir die Hymne des Sieges
singen bis dahin auf
Wiedersehen der Appell einer
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin sollte gehört
werden nicht nur in Oslo wo die Menschen
heute abend narges Mohammadi und den
Frauen in Iran
gratulieren ein Appell für Demokratie
und Menschenrechte in Iran also fragen
wir unseren Korrespondenten in thearan
Jörg Brase guten Abend wird dieser
Appell der der
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin in Iran
gehört wie reagiert das Regime
darauf also das Regime das strafte die
Verleihung heute mit nicht Achtung von
Regierung und von den Staatsmedien dazu
heute kein Wort vor zwei Monaten im
Oktober als verkündet wurde das nages
Mohammadi den Friedensnobelpreis
bekommen sollte da hatte es Kommentare
gegeben das waren dann die üblichen
Kommentare es hieß es sei eine
politische Entscheidung das sei die
Einmischung in innere Angelegenheiten
des Iran und die Feinde des des Iran
hätten nur zum Ziel das Land politisch
zu destabilisieren deshalb gibt es hier
einige die befürchten dass die Regierung
nun diesen Preis zum Vorwand nehmen
könnte um weiter hart oder vielleicht
sogar noch härter gegen seine Kritiker
vorzugehen aber die Frauen im Iran die
Protestbewegung die werden den
Friedensnobelpreis doch feiern
oder ja sicher das tun sie oder das tun
zumindest viele jetzt vielleicht nicht
mit hubkonzerten hier auf der Straße die
haben wir heute nicht gehört aber viele
sind doch der Meinung dass es sich bei
dem Preis um ein sehr wichtiges und
starkes Symbol handelt wir haben heute
mit einer Frau gprochen die an den
Protesten teilgenommen hat die hat uns
gesagt das ist ein Preis für alle
iranischen Frauen und auch ein Preis der
mir ganz persönlich sehr viel Mut macht
weiterzukämpfen sie bezieht das vor
allem auf die Kopftuchpflicht sie sagte
früher wenn ich auf die Straße gegangen
bin dann hatte ich Angst vor den
Menschen ich wusste nicht wie die Leute
reagieren heute haben wir nur noch Angst
vor dem Regime die Stimmung auf den
Straßen die haben sich verändert es gäbe
immer mehr Menschen die es tolerieren
würden äh wenn sie ohne Kopf tuuch
herumlaufen und wenn es dann mal Kritik
oder auch Angriffe geäbe meinte sie dann
gibt es immer mehr Menschen vor allem
Männer die sich dann schützen vor sich
stellen es gebe nur eine Situation in
der sie einen Kompromiss machen würde
hat sie uns erzählt und das sei das
Kopftuch im Auto das wird immer stärker
und kontrolliert es gibt Verwarnungen
und im Wiederholungsfalle wird gedroht
dass der Wagen stillgelegt wird da sagte
sie uns ich brauche mein Auto also
insofern ziehe ich im Wagen das Kopftuch
wieder an aber sonst lasse ich es Weg
die Zeit für den großen Wandel meinte
sie die ist noch nicht gekommen aber wir
machen kleine Schritte sie sagte im
Laufe des vergangenen Jahres seit seit
die Proteste losgegangen sind da sind
wir Frauen in Iran immer mutiger
geworden wir lassen uns immer weniger
Vorschriften machen danke für diese
Schilderung Jörg Brase war das live aus
Teran und bei uns geht's weiter mit
Nachrichten aus dem Sport mit heans Wolf
zuerst zur Fußball Bundesliga im
Spitzenspiel Stuttgart Leverkusen gab es
keinen Sieger entstand ein zu ein
Unentschieden Leverkusen weiter an der
Tabellenspitze vor den Bayern und
Stuttgart auf Platz 3 in der zweiten
Partie dieses Sonntags gab es ebenfalls
ein Unentschieden Köln und Mainz
trentnen sich torlos alle Höhepunkte des
14 Spieltags ab Mitternacht bei ZDF
heute und in der ZDF heute App im DFB
Pokal sind die Viertelfinalpartien für
Ende Januar und Anfang Februar 2024
ausgelost worden es spielen sabrücken
gegen Mönchen glladbach Herter BSC gegen
Kaisers Lautern Leverkusen gegen
Stuttgart und stankt pauli gegen Fortuna
Düsseldorf zweites springen und zweiter
Sieg für Karl Geiger beim Heimweltcup in
klingental Geiger siegte vor dem
Schweizer Gregor Deschwanden und seinem
DSV Teamkollegen Andreas Wellinger es
war der 15 weltcuperfolg seiner
Karriere
die deutschen Bob Pilotinnen und Piloten
haben beim Weltcup im französischen
laplanje gleich mehrfach triumpiert im
Zweier Bob Rennen der Frauen siegte
Olympiasiegerin Laura Nolte vor
Weltmeisterin Kim kaliki beim Vierer Bob
der Männer gewann Olympiasieger und
Rekordweltmeister Francesco Friedrich
vor seinem Dauerrivalen Johannes Lochner
dritter wurde der Oberhofer Adam Amur
bei seinem Weltcup
debü der Mann ist ein Phänomen sein
Roman Der Vorleser wurde in über 50
Sprachen übersetzt und schaffte es als
erstes deutsches Werk überhaupt auf
Platz 1 der Bestsellerliste der New York
Times er ist auch ein angesehener Jurist
er war Professor für öffentliches Recht
und Rechtsphilosophie und Richter am
Verfassungsgerichtshof von
Nordrhein-Westfalen als Jurist und als
Schriftsteller bedient sich Bernhard
Schlink einer genauen klaren knappen
Sprache so die Kritik Fernsehinterviews
gibt er eigentlich nie außer Claudio
Armbruster der seinen neuen Roman das
späte Leben
vorstellt die Geschichte beginnt mit
einem Schock ein Mann bekommt die
Diagnose dass ihm nur noch wenige Monate
zu leben bleiben doch der Autor Bernhard
Schlink setzt noch einen drauf als
dieser Mann seine Ehefrau von der Arbeit
abholen will muss er mit ansehen dass
sie ihn
betrügt
[Musik]
Martin fasste nicht was er sah aber was
gab es zu fassen kann man zwei Männer
lieben oder denkt man man könnte es und
belügt sich und belog er sich wenn er
Bratwurst mit Kartoffeln und grünkohlaas
und walsrote biertrank als sein nichts
als müsste er nicht
sterben der Roman den der 79-Jährige
Schlink da geschrieben hat heißt das
späte
Leben und als Leser ist die erste Frage
die mir in den Sinn kommt geht es ihnen
gut vielen Dank mir geht es gut und
nein nein ich habe hier keine eigene
biographische Geschichte geschrieben
Entwarnung also und
aufatmen das Moll in dem dieser Roman
beginnt ist schwermütig der nahende Tod
ist als Thema nicht gerade erbaulich
aber die Geschichte nimmt dann fahrt auf
wenn Liebe und Eifersucht ins Spiel
kommen Eifersucht bringt ja vielleicht
nie was aber in dem Stadium schon gar
nichts und er versucht über diese
Eifersucht
hinwegzukommen und zu nehmen und sich zu
freuen an dem was nach wie vor ist warum
soll die die Angst vor dem nahen Tod die
Lust an Erotik und Sexualität
nehmen die
schlinksprache präzise und berührend was
gehörte sich in seiner Situation gab es
ein Gefühl dass man im Angesicht des
Todes zu haben hatte und manchmal
geschah es dass er vor dem Tod erschrag
dem nicht der lere der Kälte
dann schämte er sich das nichts ist
nichts was gab es da zu
erschrecken ja so ist
es was gibt es da zu
erschrecken trotzdem erschrecken wir
manchmal aber wir können uns dann immer
sagen eigentlich gibt es nicht zu
erschrecken seinen Frieden machen mit
der Diagnose und auch mit der untreuen
Liebe ist so traurig wie tröstlich und
trotz aller schwere ganz
leicht ein
Winterbuch und jetzt haben wir noch den
Blick in die neue Woche für Sie mit den
Ereignissen die wir schon voraussehen
können franziska feske hat sie
[Musik]
zusammengestellt am Montag wird Polens
noch amtierender Ministerpräsident mor
im Parlament Vertrauensfrage stellen und
aller Erwartung nach verlieren denn er
und seine peacepartei wurden bei der
Wahl im Oktober zwar stärkste Kraft
fanden jedoch keine Koalitionspartner
Kontrahent Donald Tusk hingegen hat sich
seine Mehrheit schon per
Koalitionsvertrag gesichert und wartet
nun auf den
Regierungsauftrag am Mittwoch wird im
EU-Parlament in Straßburg der
sacharovpreis für Menschenrechte
verliehen dieses Jahr werden die
iranische Frauenbewegung und Gina Masa
Amini ausgezeichnet die 22-Jährige war
vergangenes Jahr von der Sittenpolizei
gewaltsam verhaftet worden und daraufhin
gestorben ihr Tod hatte landesweite
Proteste
ausgelöst ab Donnerstag werden sich die
EU Staats und Regierungschefs in Brüssel
treffen mit pallgefüllter Tagesordnung
es geht um viel Geld und darum wie es
verteilt wird die Ukraine etwa soll neue
Finanzhilfen bekommen außerdem sollen
Beitrittsverhandlungen aufgenommen
werden Ungarns premier orbahn lehnt
beides bislang ab und droht damit den
Gipfel scheitern zu
lassen noch zum Wetter es gibt eine
aktuelle Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor starkem
Tauwetter in Teilen Bayerns und jetzt zu
den Aussichten für morgen an den Alpen
gibt es zum Tauwetter ergiebigen Regen
auch nördlich des Mains regnet es
verbreitet dazwischen sind schauerelten
bei einem starken Westwind werden 6 bis
14° erreicht die Aussichten am Dienst AG
regnet es im Westen und Süden an den
Alpen weiterhin stark auch am Mittwoch
regnet es verbreitet die regenintensität
an den Alpen lässt aber nach am
Donnerstag wird es mit 1 bis 6° wieder
kühler das war's von uns hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit der deutschbelgischen
Krimiserie Juliet und einem Tod in den
Dünen von den von deh und die nächste
heute Express gibt's dann gegen 0:20 Uhr
Morgen begrüßen Sie hier Heinz Wolf und
Maria lomka haben Sie einen schönen
Abend tschüss
[Musik]
wiedersehen